Espero que ahora ya sepamos un poquito más
acerca de las variables
y como vimos en el video anterior, las variables se pueden designar a través de cualquier símbolo,
aunque usualmente usamos letras pues estamos acostumbrados a escribir con ellas.
Así podríamos usar "x", "y", "z", "a", "b",
o inclusive podríamos usar letras griegas
como teta, cualquier símbolo puede usarse,
de tal manera que al verlo,
puedes detectar que es una variable, puede tener múltiples valores,
pero de todos estos, el que más típicamente representa una variable es la letra "x".
Aunque los demás se usan de alguna manera,
pero dado que la letra "x" es la que se usa comúnmente,
esto tiene un pequeño inconveniente,
el problema es que la "x" se parece mucho
al símbolo de multiplicación que usamos
en aritmética, así si queremos escribir
2 por 3, esto se escribe como 2 x 3, pero
ahora que estamos usando variables,
si quisiera escribir por ejemplo, 2 por "x", lo escribiría
de la siguiente manera, 2 x "x",
observa que el símbolo de por y la "x" son muy similares,
ese es precisamente el problema
y si no tenemos cuidado con el tamaño de la letra,
no sabríamos lo que esto significa,
significa, 2 por por ó 2 x x,
¿qué significa en realidad esto?
Y dado que esto es confuso...
esto de aquí es confuso y puede malinterpretarse,
evitamos a toda costa usar este símbolo para
designar multiplicaciones en álgebra.
En vez de eso, tenemos varias opciones en
álgebra para indicar multiplicación,
una de ellas es por ejemplo, si queremos indicar
2 por "x", lo indicaríamos como,
2·x, es importante aclarar que este punto,
no es un punto decimal,
este lo escribimos ligeramente más alto y lo escribimos así para no confundirnos entre esto
y estos símbolos que designan variables, pero esto si lo podemos interpretar como 2 por "x".
Así por ejemplo, si alguien nos dice
¿cuánto es 2·x cuando "x" es igual a 3?
Pues esto es exactamente lo mismo, a 2 por 3,
cuando "x" es igual a 3.
Otra manera de escribir esto es, 2 y la "x"
la ponemos entre paréntesis después del 2.
Esto también significa 2 por "x", de nueva cuenta, si en este caso "x" fuera 7, esto sería 2 por 7 ó 14.
Pero la manera más tradicional de hacerlo
es escribir la "x" justo después del 2
y esto se va a leer como "2x", pero esto,
de hecho significa 2 por "x".
Y aquí podrías preguntar,
¿cómo es que esto no lo hicimos acá arriba?
Bueno, si lo hubiéramos hecho aquí... pero
si hubiéramos escrito esto como 23,
bueno esto más que 2 por 3, indica el número 23,
por eso nunca lo hacemos así,
pero aquí que estamos usando una letra, es claro que
esto no es parte del número,
esto no es veintialgo, esto significa 2 por "x".
Así es que estas tres representan lo mismo,
2 por "x", 2 por "x", 2 por "x".
Habiendo visto esto, hagamos algunos ejemplos.
Algunos ejercicios para que practiques esto
y que te vayas preparando para ejemplos posteriores.
Si tenemos, 10 menos "3y" y queremos saber
cuanto vale esto cuando "y" es igual a 2,
bueno, donde hay "y" sustituimos por 2, así
es que tenemos que "y" es igual a 2,
aquí hay una "y", vamos a sustituirlo por 2,
esto nos va a dar, 10 menos 3 por 2,
aquí recordemos que la multiplicación
tiene precedencia sobre la resta,
así es que esto sería 3 por 2 = 6 y 10 menos 6...
10 menos 6 es igual a 4.
Hagamos otro.
Supongamos que tenemos... no sé... a ver,
vamos a hacer...
Supongamos que tenemos 7, "7x"...
"7x" menos 4...
déjame hacerlo con otro color...
"7x" menos 4.
Y queremos evaluar eso cuando "x"...
cuando "x" es igual a 3.
Entonces, donde veamos "x" sustituimos por 3.
Así es que aquí tenemos, 7...
voy a poner el color original...
7 por...
y voy a usar esta anotación que se puede
usar con números...
esto sería 7 por 3... 7 por 3 menos 4.
Y de nueva cuenta la multiplicación tiene
precedencia sobre la suma o la resta,
así es que esto es 7 por 3 = 21 y finalmente,
21 menos 4 es igual a 17.
Espero que esto te haya dado buenas bases,
y te invito a que realices los ejercicios
que te voy a dar posteriormente,
en los cuales podrás practicar el evaluar
expresiones como estas.